you know we love on the show did I think
you're a giant fan of his planner we are
where our favorite musical act is a
thera-band called JD in the straight
shot yes yes billionaire Blues guy it
makes me so happy the guy because he
brings such soul and such advanced
lyrical the soul is what it is though
because like like the like oh III once
never owned any buildings in New York
and then I always dreamed of being an
NBA owner and then daddy gave me a team
Dan a James Dolan I was thinking that
maybe we could watch the music video for
better than a church because it might be
great to get Michael's reaction because
he really is good in music videos like a
lot of guys jump around music videos
that are glide which is a better video I
mean I feel like better find a church
has become our anthem that's why I
picked it but glide is also great cuz
glide he smiles a lot and his hands are
where they belong like he looks good in
a video like I might never seen this
okay what do you want a church sure do
you want a ski so I'll let you guys take
the Lucas where's Travis take self yeah
yeah we need we need it in the streets
you know what Troy you you've been on
board with all this do you pick glide or
better find a church better find a
church is the hit it's the interim come
on show produced video okay and then
yeah and then at some point well we'll
have you do glide it isn't Kravis uncle
better find a garden very good his
lyrics he writes the lyrics they're so
good he's a really big baby you know
he's like the he exudes pain and like
when you think of Blues it's like Albert
King BB King [ __ ] James Dolan like
it's like you know so yeah he's a
bluesman chap assessment
[Music]
no I can't [ __ ] pockets that believe
this [ __ ] what do you mean what can't
you believe look at this [ __ ] guy
James don't you know like his hands oh
look at his hat it's great one of the
great blues me I think so
now this [ __ ] guy look he's got a
natural buttoned his natural hair color
and as I'm ready you're happy he doesn't
look like a gnome like he doesn't look
like something from Game of Thrones no
either hands of pockets for life yes
belt them out it just feels totally
comfortable in front of camera yeah I
don't think he used a sharpie to color
his eyebrow no no his beard is that
color yeah I think so I really believe
they just were hanging out in this
church and they just decided they just
decided to sing it happening it seems
authentic it came wow you know these
other three people in his band are
probably like lifelong struggling
musician miserable and then I got to
work with this [ __ ] clown to get paid
good for them but can you imagine just
showing up and having the lyrics brought
to you and then going I get to play
music to these lyrics well let's listen
to some of the lyrics yeah
Wow Jesus you look so goddamn damn you
know this [ __ ] is I never saw this and
my my my feelings about the Knicks and
James Dolan's are so frustrating they
should put this is crazy to me can you
put a little bit of glide just the video
yeah you got a negative vibe on James
doll I don't like it
glide has a nice outdoorsy feel yeah
that was weird that you didn't like that
one Michael you're like you're like God
I'm not getting it this is blues sign I
get it but the outdoor the fun side for
Peter you're the happiness this is the
Jim doll and I like yeah
JD in the straight shot it's good stuff
Axl yeah our doors on a ski slope yeah
he probably owns a mountain oh my
goodness gracious
way look at this [ __ ] guy but instead
gliding moved his hands on a client I
didn't know what he meant until he did
holy [ __ ] look at his natural teeth and
he's smiling in in those teeth yeah they
the same colors they're glistening
frolicking and they're just having fun
having fun it's just a day it's just an
afternoon out in the Sun wait until the
verse kicks in yeah let him stand there
who comes up with the concept for this
video what's the poem it's James Jules
that's fun James [ __ ] don't see
another in a club just jamming huh hey
you don't like your ears are [ __ ]
broken yeah he always teeth are the same
length which look which means they're
always natural that's right can you ask
how many views of this video actually
have I mean ever it is only four of them
are not from this show 44,000 look at
the snow dog JD in the straight shot are
you enjoying them you failed man I'm
blown away by this [ __ ] you know they
got to open for the Eagles in a building
that James Dolan owns right yeah I'm
sure the Eagles requested that yeah they
were like yeah of course we want JD in
the streets got to open for us and a lot
of people came just to see JD in the
street soon as they start a hotel
California people like we've heard this
but yeah the truth is everyone just
stayed for glide yeah Wow
yeah hey he goes you better find a
church all right that could that poor
girl having to make eye contact with
James Dolan released theorized to and
you watch the videos she's very she's
amazing and she's sexy she looks him in
the eye and like there's a weird flirt
going on like where she's convincing him
I love you and you're owning me like
yeah it's amazing how
we're connecting oh yeah music about the
blues until as long as those checks
clear we're getting a musical level get
clear and even though these shits
existed man we spent a lot of hours
watch his stage presence wouldn't like
the on stage stuff I mean you just feel
it like he seems comfortable up on stage
huh
and he just feels like he was meant to
be there and I don't feel like he ever I
had to cut any corners that's what I'm
saying if there's one joints like Pryor
like little gigs in Alabama I like
playing the blue circuit Deacon blues
this is what your weekend is gonna be
after every stress factory show you're
to go back to the hotel and you're gonna
go on a loop and you're gonna hate watch
these you have to watch the one what's
the video that he does we want Ali who
Bali who watch Bali Bali hood thank you
for the rolls the sleeves up you're
gonna go crazy love it you quantify it
make sure it's the live version is
better yes yeah I feel like you got like
four to five podcasts in you just
dedicated to all the content as a matter
of fact if you want to come back and
just do a day with us Oh James Dolan you
honestly do Dolan D in the Straits do
you think anyone calls him JD I would
the stray shots do
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]